spuren des krieges prägen das stadtbild
die region don was es seit acht jahren
umkämpft auf der einen seite
pro-russische separatisten auf der
anderen das ukrainische militär seit
einigen wochen haben die gefechte wieder
zugenommen die narben des krieges
begutachtet nicolai täglich hier
bitteschön wir haben die kugeln
getroffen und
guck mal hier steckt sogar noch etwas
vom projektil drin
eigentlich wollte die stadt sein haus
längst renoviert haben doch passiert es
nichts die großen löcher hat er selber
notdürftig gestopft die brüchige mauer
hält der kälte schon lange nicht mehr
stand und holz ist teuer die kleine
rente von umgerechnet 100 euro deckt
gerade so seine heizkosten die menschen
hier hätten keine kraft mehr für den
krieg sagt nicolai seit 2014 gebe es nur
noch zerstörung und leid dabei sein
russen ukraine doch einmal brüder
gewesen
den servicezeiten lebten wir alle
zusammen kasachen viele russen russen
und ukrainer und plötzlich wegen
irgendwelchen politikern ist unsere
union zerbrochen
und nun spitzt sich die situation wieder
bedrohlich zu russland soll über 100.000
soldaten an der grenze zur ukraine
stationiert haben
ich glaube es zwar nicht aber
wenn sie wirklich einmarschieren dann
wird das der dritte weltkrieg denn
niemand will
was macht das mit ihm
ich habe überhaupt keine angst mehr
überhaupt keine angst mehr
er zeigt uns im hof den selbst gebauten
keller wo sie 2014 wochen lang ausharren
mussten als granaten und kugeln auf das
haus niedergingen er seine frau die
tochter mit seinen zwei enkeltöchtern
noch dient der keller nur als
vorratskammer der keller ist
bombensicher
auch jetzt
dieser keller
wird wieder standhalten
die enkeltöchter sind heute neun und elf
jahre alt nicolai holt sie wie jeden tag
von der schule ab
die eltern von nastia und katja sind
arbeiten deswegen übernimmt der oper ein
heizen kochen und das wichtigste kinder
jetzt hausaufgaben
aufgaben hause kommen äußerlich herrscht
in den dörfern im donbass normalität
aber das trauma des krieges ist
allgegenwärtig auch bei nastia und der
kleinen schwester katja die den frieden
nie erlebt haben katja kann sich kaum an
die wochen und keller erinnern die
elfjährige nastia schon sie war damals
drei
als katja klein war wurde sie von mama
in tücher eingewickelt beging in den
keller dann schlugen die geschosse ein
es waren granaten dann gab es eine
schießerei
bisher keine fragen mehr
das was sie hinter sich haben könnte
wieder passieren
drei autostunden entfernt einstand in
der stadt katif dimitrow probt den
ernstfall
er will unerkannt bleiben
ich arbeite für die verteidigungs
abteilung sollte die stadt besetzt
werden werde ich schläfer
die zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine könnte
die erste sein die von den russen
erobert wird spekulierte vergangene
woche der ukrainische präsident
in diesem fall wird soll da die metro
hier bleiben als schläfer und unerkannt
informationen sammeln für das
ukrainische militär er ist russe stimmig
wie viele hier
aktiv ist seine heimatstadt ein
wichtiges handelszentrum mit viel
industrie und damit strategisch
bedeutsam
2014 herrscht krieg mal gewinnen wie er
mal verlieren wir und seitdem steht eine
besetzung der stadt immer wieder im raum
archiv grenzt an die kriegsregion im don
was wir könnten hier jeden moment auch
besetzt werden
doch dieses mal sei die anspannung
größer auch seine vorbereitungen laufen
insbesondere die wie er seine frau und
den kleinen sohn evakuieren kann beide
sollen im kriegsfall in die west ukraine
fliegen ein plan den hier viele
verfolgen doch noch bleiben die meisten
natürlich habe ich angst aber angst
sollte niemals siegen
zurück im donbass dort wo 2014 der krieg
begann nikolai ist müde von der kälte
der armut dem leben das er seit acht
jahren führt er hat nur diesen einen
großen wunsch trüben
verlieren will nicolai die hoffnung
nicht aber er hat in diesen tagen
zweifel und große sorge ob er das mit
dem frieden noch erleben wird
[Musik]